j'étais au téléphone la foudre a suivi
la ligne elle a pénétré mon cou a
traversé ma colonne vertébrale et emma
projeté en l'air
j'avais un léger bourdonnement
d'oreilles je me suis sentie sortir de
mon corps je flottais le plafond le
médecin et l'infirmière me regardent ils
ont dit c'est fini
elle est morte
on m'a transporté à l'hôpital les
médecins ont fait tout ce qu'ils ont pu
mais j'ai été déclaré mort
j'ai réalisé que j'étais sorti de mon
corps lorsque j'ai aperçu cette lumière
de ce qui me rassure j'ai un être
extraordinaire
c'était comme un total oubli de soi une
compréhension une volonté un amour
absolu
un amour merveilleux
la vie après la vie
après avoir baigné un moment dans cette
lumière
ils ont dû effectuer le voyage de retour
il explique que s'ils ont choisi de
revenir c'était pas pour eux-mêmes
on aurait préféré rester dans cette
ambiance ou d'amour lorsqu'il nous
rejoignent leur histoire devient
captivante en termes de psychologie
humaine
une carence rencontre qu'ils ont
profondément changé qui sont imprégnés
d'une nouvelle notion des valeurs
auparavant le but de leur vie c'était la
richesse le pouvoir la célébrité
ce à quoi la plupart des gens mas pignou
mais ils disent qu après cette
expérience ils essaient surtout d'aimer
les autres d'entretenir des relations
harmonieuses avec leur prochain
il a viennent aussi qu'ils n'ont plus du
tout peur de la mort
je suis la docteure hamoudi ces faits
sont racontées par ceux qui les ont
réellement vécu
il ne s'agit pas de fiction mais de six
expériences authentiques parmi 2000 cas
de mort approcher
allô bonjour maman comment vas-tu que ce
qui se passe
qu'est ce qui lui est arrivé
ce coup de téléphone m'a donné le choc
que tout le monde redoute espère ne
jamais recevoir
il ya tant de sentiments que je voudrais
exprimer
je dois être avec toi
que à bientôt
je t'aime maman
mon père lutter contre la mort mais ses
chances étaient faibles
nous habitions à 1000 kilomètres l'un de
l'autre nous nous voyons qu'au vacances
mais nous vivions sur la même planète
il nous suffisait de décrocher le
téléphone pour le dire bonjour
l'idée de perdre tout cela m'était
intolérable
cher papa
je suis désolé de ces mauvais moments tu
es en train de passer
je sais que tu es solide mais tu nous as
fait une sacrée peur
cher papa je t'écris cette lettre parce
que je ne sais pas si nous nous
reverrons j'ai tant de choses à te dire
te souviens-tu il y a plusieurs années
lorsque j'étais sous le coup du décès de
fezzan j'ai trouvé un grand réconfort
dans des livres qui traitait de la mort
1 époque j'ai rencontré un psychiatre le
docteur raymond midi je t'envoie un
exemplaire de son livre qui m'avait
beaucoup aidé le dr moody observé un
phénomène commun à des gens de toutes
cultures et de toutes religions
en fait leurs croyances et leur passé ne
détermine temps rien aventure qu'ils ont
vécu ni son compte
oui certains qui précédemment était
cotée ou agnostiques ont connu aux
frontières de la mort cette expérience
épanouissante
ils sont restés à thé ou deux mais une
fois revenu nous ont dit qu'il se
sentait transformé qui n'avait plus
aucun doute sur l'existence d'un dieu
n'est sur une forme de vie après la mort
c'est le sujet des recherches qu'il a
menées sur les récits de gens confrontés
à la mort qui l'ont expérimenté qui
témoigne j'ai eu l'impression d'être
heurté par un train en fait j'étais au
téléphone je serrais le cornet comme
ceci la foudre est descendu le long de
la ligne aide à pénétrer mon coude et a
traversé ma colonne vertébrale et m'a
projeté en l'air mais elle avait soulevé
au sol les clous des talons de mes
chaussures le fait que ce soit ainsi
relié à la terre mais éviter d'exploser
on me tire une balle dans le corps j'ai
situer l'emplacement de mon coeur j'ai
posé le canon contre ma poitrine
j'ai appuyé sur la gâchette
je n'avais pas réagi comme ans on est le
médecin venu examiner et s'il a dit je
lis perdu
je pensais une équipe indique-t-il juste
auparavant j'avais ressenti une forte
douleur je souffrais tellement que je
voulais partir quelques minutes avant
qu'arrive la jeep qui deviennent
transporter on s'est rendu compte que
j'avais une forte fièvre
plutôt que d'attendre le capitaine qui
était un garde à l'hôpital m'a emmené au
rayon la dernière chose dont je me
souviens c'est que le radiologue m'a
demandé si je pensais pouvoir m'asseoir
au temps qu'il prenne une radio de
monteur axe me rappelle ronronnement des
rayons x un déclic me suis roulé
d'abeilles je me suis vite rendu compte
qu'il y avait un problème
j ai téléphoné à delettes une autre base
était à environ 5 km j'ai tenté
d'appeler mon patron je suis tombé et
j'ai perdu connaissance
heureusement un peu plus tard mon patron
est passé en voiture
il a remarqué que je n'étais pas à mon
poste je gisait à terre
il a appelé une ambulance en union
soviétique
j'étais ce qu'on appelle un dissident
j'ai reçu une invitation à me rendre aux
états unis
c'était en 1975 en 1976 on va accorder
un visa de sortie
ce jour là je partais pour new york
times m de neige allait retirer mon
passeport
ma famille m'attendais déjà l'aéroport
j'étais sur le trottoir quand j'ai été
renversée par une voiture
c'était le kgb voulait me tuer pour pour
m'empêcher de partis mettre mon corps
m'a conduit à l'hôpital les médecins ont
fait tout ce qu'ils ont pu pour me
sauver
mais j'ai été déclaré mort un peu
partout dans le monde nous avons relevé
le même genre d'expérience les témoins
racontent qu'au moment où leurs médecins
à constater leur décès il pouvait même
l'entendre dire il est mort où nous
l'avons perdue ou quelque chose de ce
genre
il affirme que même se sentait bien
vivant et ils ont le sentiment d'être
parfaitement conscients ils ont
l'impression de quitter leur propre
corps pour aller et flotter au plafond
de la salle d'opération de leur chambre
d'hôpital
il regarde vers le bas et aperçoivent
leur enveloppe charnelle couché sur leur
lit en dessous de chez planet ingo déjà
entouré cette affaire mais je n'avais
déjà plus conscience que les témoin tout
à coup j'ai entendu il est parti
il est parti c'était l'infirmier qui
disait cela à son collègue et moi
j'étais derrière lui je le regardais
manipuler mon corps du soudain de
l'agitation dessous j'ai remarqué que
des gens poussés la civière dans le
couloir mais je ne m'intéressait pas
vraiment à mon corps je me souciais
plutôt de deux policiers en civil qui se
trouvait près de mon revolver
l'un d'eux se tromper à propos d'un
détail et j'essayais de lui dire je
pouvais voir les militaires les
infirmières les médecins mais ne me
voyais pas
jallet de salle en salle et de lian li
pour trouver un soldat qui me ressemble
je me désespère est de plus en plus en
rencontrant ces êtres humains sans
pouvoir communiquer avec eux finalement
je suis entré dans une salle d'isolement
il y avait là un homme couché sous un
drap et bien j'ai dû admettre que
c'était moi en reconnaissant ma bague
qu'il portait au doigt
j'avais un léger bourdonnement donné je
me suis sentie sentir comme encore je
sais pas comment mais je me suis soudain
trouvé hors de moi même je me suis
assise à la tête du lit pendant une
minute
regardant tout autour de moi puis je me
suis sentie flotter au plafond je
regardais vers le bas quelqu'un disait
elle est partie je n'arrivais pas à le
croire
je me demandais mais qui est parti
autour de moi je sentais des présences
c'était des anges gardiens je les
appelais mykid j'ai tout à coup observer
une lumière qui provenait du coin de la
chambre
j'ai immédiatement pensé mais tout vient
tél et elle m'a dit j'ai toujours été là
mais vous ne pouviez pas vous en rendre
compte
si je dit elle c'est parce que cette
lumière irradie un abandon de soins un
amour dévorant une compréhension une
bonté
bref autant de qualités que je
considérais comme spécifiquement
féminine
il affirme qu'après un moment il
commence à éprouver un indescriptible
sentiment de féliciter quelque chose qui
transcende les mots qui est
intraduisible dans notre langage
quotidien
un homme m'a dit que juste avant son
expérience il ressentait une forte
douleur dans la poitrine et qu'aussitôt
après avoir quitté son corps il se
sentit envahis par une énorme sensation
de joie et de paix une sorte d'extase
je me sentais l'homme et le corps
parfaitement lisse c'était à la fois
stupéfiants et captivant j'étais heureux
de vivre une expérience parce que je
percevais leurs pensées je pouvais tout
voir je pouvais tout sentir je pouvais
entendre et capter leurs pensées c'était
surtout cela qui me rendait joyeux et
fier je ne sais si le mot est approprié
mais je me sens très fier de pouvoir
lire leurs pensées je me souviens
d'avoir trouvé très excitant de me
trouver hors est au dessus de moi
c'était pas du tout angoisse j'ai su que
j'étais supposé rester auprès de mon
corps alors je le suivis dans les
couloirs jusqu'à la porte
cela me faisait un drôle d'effet mais à
l'extérieur c'est devenu merveilleux
j'adorerais pouvoir regarder à travers
les parois de l'ambulance tout en
restant en dehors
c'était une merveilleuse expérience ses
lumières
cette impression de légèreté lorsque je
suis sortie de moi-même je n'ai éprouvé
aucune douleur et j'étais libre je
n'étais plus la femme la mère ou la
fille de quelqu'un j'étais simplement
moi je me souviens parfaitement de
mettre regarder et d'avoir songé je suis
plus beau que ça car ce gars était laid
il était en mauvais état sa figure était
parcourue de ligne bleue et j'étais
enchanté vraiment heureux d'être éloigné
de ce corps il pouvait le garder je ne
ressentais ni regret ni sentiment de
tristesse quoi qu'il ait pu arriver
pratiquement cela ne m'ennuie et pas du
tout je voyais mon corps et je le
détestais je ne voulais pas y retourner
je voulais un être faible et malade
après un moment j'ai eu la brusque
révélation c'était moi il essayait de le
ranimer
j'étais un très beau doigt
oui en fait mon coeur s'était arrêté moi
je reste en partie sceptique je me
demande si ces gens n'ont pas éprouvé
simplement des hallucinations
ce qui ne s'agit pas d'un processus
naturel du un arrêt de fonctionnement du
cerveau je me suis posée aux trois fois
la même question
ce qui m'a convaincu c'est que ces
témoins sont capables de fournir une
description précise des événements qui
se sont produits durant leur
résurrection et donc il ne pouvait avoir
connaissance de l'endroit où il se
trouvait j'ai par exemple une amie qui
travaille dans une faculté de médecine
de l'ouest et bien elle a été appliquée
dans la résurrection d'une jeune fille
du nom de marianne on a décru que mariah
était morte mais on a réussi à la
ranimer
lorsqu'elle a repris conscience mon ami
était à ses côtés
maria s'est accroché llb a affirmé
qu'elle s'était sentie sortir de son
corps qu'il avait quitté le bâtiment et
qu'elle avait alors une vieille
chaussure posé sur un appui de fenêtre à
l'un des étages supérieurs de l'hôpital
mon ami est allé jusqu'à cet endroit
elle a pu elle-même vérifier que la
chaussure se trouvait bien là où l'avait
dit maria
j'ai soudain pris conscience de
plusieurs présences dans le couloir la
salle avait été fermé car on allait
pratiquer une opération
je suis sorti par la porte
je n'ai pas ouvertes gelé simplement
franchi
je me suis retrouvée de l'autre côté
dans le golfe je me suis dirigé vers ma
fille j'essayais de lui dire cattier
rentrer à la maison pour de changer mais
elle me donnait pas alors j'ai dit à son
père une jupe ramène katia la maison
pour qu'il se change alors qu'il restait
dans le couloir et que j'essayais de les
renvoyer un frère de mon mari est arrivé
on lui avait transmis le message d'un de
ses voisins étaient aussi à l'hôpital et
engager la conversation lui a demandé ce
qu'il faisait et quels étaient ses
projets il lui a répondu je crois que ma
belle soeur va casser sa pipe
je pensais aller athènes et je vais
rester pour porter un cordon du poil je
vais raconter cela plus tard il a dû
finir parallèle c'est bien ce qu'il
avait dit je me suis moqué de lui parce
qu'il était embarrassé
c'était incroyable je ne t'ai jamais mon
corps je pouvais me rendre dans tous les
endroits auxquels je pensais et avec mon
corps
je ne quittais pas un endroit pour un
euro j'étais partout en même temps je
pouvais être à la fois à new york au
texas à moscou et tbilissi partout pour
moi les distances et le temps était
aboli un moment j'ai eu envie de voir m
je me suis aussitôt retrouvé à rockville
dans le mile
elle se préparait à faire des courses
elle portait un tailleur beige et une
blouse verte
elle devait rentrer chez elle pour
récupérer ses clés qu'elle avait égaré
elle est ensuite sorti pour monter dans
sa chevrolet blement je me suis dit
qu'il n'était pas nécessaire de la
compagnie en magasin je laisser partir
pour faire un saut chez une autre soeur
à quelques kilomètres de là je me suis
aperçue qu'elle n'était pas chez elle
elle aussi faisait des courses alors mes
guides m'a demandé si j'étais prête à
quitter la région
j'aurais répondu que j'étais d'accord
deux semaines après mon expérience de me
rapprocher
j'ai été en contact avec je lui ai
décrit la scène elle m'a dit comment tu
peux savoir tout ça je n'étais pas vu
n'était pas
j'arrivais à communiquer avec des
enfants très jeunes encore incapable de
parler et de marché un petit avec
lesquels j'ai réussi à entrer en
communication une communication
spirituel n'utilisions pas de mots
c'était un contact le mental
une petite fille blanche cassé personne
ne comprenait pourquoi elle pleurait si
fort ses parents et le médecin était
j'ai dit à la fillette ne pleure pas de
toute façon personne ne comprendra
pourquoi tu pleures
elle a cessé de sangloter elle a souri
les gens qui l'entouraient étaient
étonnés ils ont regardé et se sont
demandé ce qui arrivait
pourquoi elle avait soudain si simple je
voulais leur expliquer mais avec eux je
ne réussissais pas à communiquer après
le 3e journée et lorsque j'ai réintégré
mon corps lorsque j'ai pu entendre et je
n'aurais dit votre fille pleure parce
qu'elle à la hanche cassée voilà le
diagnostic et vous recherchez
ils se sont rendus compte que c'était la
vérité et ils ont été stupéfaits
je me suis aussi demandé si les gens ne
décrirai pas simplement des lieux qu'ils
avaient connus précédemment et dont il
se souvenait oui c'était mon cas ils se
rendent là où ils ont déjà été mais
aussi parfois dans des lieux dont il
ignorait l'existence
le dr richie par exemple a été amené à
retrouver un endroit qu'il avait
découvert durant son expérience extra
corporelle
com
j'avais quitté la chambre pour me rendre
à vicksburg dans le mississippi j'ai vu
un homme qui s'apprêtait à rentrer dans
un bar de nuit d'une façade blanche au
sein d'une rue je lui ai demandé si
c'était la bonne direction pour aller à
richmond
l'homme a eu la même attitude qui a
garçons de salle que j'avais rencontrée
en marchant dans les couloirs de
l'hôpital comme s'il ne pouvait ni voir
ni entendre
en fait j'avais traversé son corps je
voulais simplement rentré à richmond et
cela ne m'avait pas arrêté comme cet
autre gars ne réussissait pas à me voir
je me suis dit qu'il y avait quelque
chose qui clochait qui empêchait qu'on
aperçoive et qu'on m'entende
j'ai su que j'avais été avec ce bloc dix
mois après lorsque je suis passé dans
cette vidéo j'ai reconnu le café au coin
de la rue le temps et l'espace tels que
nous les percevons n'existe pas du
simple fait de souhaiter me rendre à
richmond
j'aurais pu me trouver
avant de te parler de la forme la plus
aventureuse de voyages extra corporelle
je voudrais que tu me promettent de
venir me dire au revoir avant de quitter
ce monde des gens ont vécu une autre
forme d' expérience extraordinaire
après avoir quitté leur corps ils se
sont élevées au dessus de la terre ils
ont voyagé loin dans l'espace le dr carl
jung
le grand psychiatre suisse avec une
telle expérience de mort approcher
il y a une cinquantaine d'années lors
d'une crise cardiaque
edit au début de 1944 je me suis cassé
un pied les subit ensuite une crise
cardiaque
j'ai vécu alors des phénomènes très
étrange je planais ou dans l'espace
l'apercevait sous moi le globe terrestre
baignant dans une magnifique lumière
bleue je voyais distinctement les mers
et les océans et la neige au sommet de
l'himalaya
je me sentais sur le point de quitter la
terre où le spectacle que j'en avais de
cette aptitude et le plus merveilleux
qui n'était que de me voir
cependant dans un deuxième temps les
patients commencent à se rendre compte
que s'ils sont capables de percevoir ce
qui les entoure toute communication leur
est interdite
si les intériorise alors en quelque
sorte de leur sens d'identité ils
prennent conscience du fait que ce
qu'ils ressentent à quelque chose à voir
avec la mort c'est à ce stade
qu'interviennent les parties les plus
transcendantale de l'expérience souffrez
j'étais dans l'obscurité
je ne voyais rien ne pouvait pas bouger
la main je n'avais pas bouger le corps
j'ai alors compris je n'ai rien mais je
suis et c'est cela qui m'a fait peur la
peur à cognac
pourquoi avons nous peur dans le noir
parce qu'on ne sait pas ce qu'il ya dans
le mois cette peur
c'est la peur de l'inconnu mais là
compréhensible nous inoculent la peur de
quelque chose c'est pourquoi moi aussi
j'avais peur j'avais peur de l'obscurité
j'avais peur d'être l'âge et plus peur
encore dit être sans corps mais j'étais
vous savez j'ai une formation
scientifique
je travaillais dans le domaine de la
psychologie et du langage
j'ai étudié la physique la chimie
l'anatomie d enseignement fondé sur le
matérialisme dialectique le matérialisme
historique pour moi il était donc
impossible d'être quelque part sans son
corps était mon principal composant ma
vie encore jamais peur de mourir j'étais
déjà mort mais c'était cela l'impression
la plus étrange comprendre que vous est
il tout en n'étant pas
je pense donc je suis c'est ce que je me
suis dit je pense et par conséquent je
suis
pourquoi ne pourrais-je pas analysé
positivement ce qui se passe autour de
moi alors j'ai commencé à penser à la
lumière de l'obscurité j'ai vu jaillir
la lumière son âme a donné un show le
premier sentiment que j'ai éprouvé c'est
la nécessité d'aller vers cette lumière
ce fut ma première pensée aller vers la
lumière et le mouvement s'est produit
ils décrivent comment ils se sentent
attirés vers une sorte de lieu clos nous
apercevons un tunnel qui le traverse
rapidement et de l'autre côté il
découvre une lumière incroyablement
brillante chaude et apaisante
je ne sais pas exactement comment ni à
quel moment apprécié je suis entré dans
le tunnel mais guide me l'ont demandé
j'ai accepté je me suis sentie attirée
vers le haut le tunnel n'était pas très
large
il ne laisser place qu'à une personne à
la fois les parois ne me touchez pas
je n'ai pas tendu la main pour les
atteindre il faisait noir
je montais j'apercevais tout au bout une
lumière rien ensuite je suis entré dans
une zone grisâtre je me suis pas arrêté
pour observer ce qui se passait j'ai
poursuivi mon chemin et je suis entré
dans cette magnifique vallée de pâturage
plein de fleurs dans cette lumière
brillant magnifique de couleurs vives
rien ici n'est comparable à cela je me
souviens que j'ai ensuite entendu un
carillon par le vent de regard à 35 ou
40 degrés j'ai aperçu un tunnel il
ressemblait à une spirale qui bougeait
j'ai commencé à me glisser je continuais
à entendre les cloches
je me sentais parfaitement paisible et
tranquille il y avait une telle
différence entre l'état dans lequel se
trouvait mon corps et la paix totale qui
régnait dans cet endroit à mesure que
j'approchais de la lumière je me sentais
imprégné d'un amour que je suis
incapable de décrire
c'est c'est comme lorsque vous n'avez
plus vos parents depuis longtemps que
vous avez été séparé de votre famille et
que vous renvoyez votre père votre mère
ce sentiment que l'on éprouve lorsqu'on
est enfant un sentiment de sécurité
je savais que tout était en ordre que
tout était bien après être entré dans le
tunnel après l'avoir traversé je suis
arrivé dans une sorte de pièce très
lumineuse
j'avais peine à l'habitude et mon regard
à cette lumière vive le contraste entre
cette brillance de l'éclair et la lueur
irradiante qui régnait dans le tunnel
était un autre élément extraordinaire
cette lumière était tellement intense
qu'elle me traversaient elle nous
transpercer et les moines ne formions
qu'un
depuis des années nous utilisons
l'expression voir la lumière au bout du
tunnel
je me demande si elle est due à des gens
qui ont vécu autrefois une expérience de
morts approchait il m'est arrivé de voir
des peintures qui semble illustrer cela
et qui remonte à des centaines d'années
au xvème siècle jérôme bosch semble s'en
être aspiré dans son ascension de la
vierge à l'avant plan au bas du tableau
on aperçoit des mourants ils sont
accompagnés d'êtres surnaturels qui
portent leur attention vers le haut
au dessus d'eux un tunnel s'amorce au
bout duquel brille une lueur traversant
le tunnel
ces gens s'agenouille révérencieuse mans
baigné par cette lumière
on sait que les êtres humains ont vécu
ce genre d'expérience de toute éternité
il nous dit souvent avoir découvert dans
cette lumière des parents ou des amis
déjà mort venu pour les accueillir et
les aider à franchir le pas en arriver
là quelque chose de grandiose
j'ai vu mes parents j'ai compris qu'ils
avaient été tués par le kgb à muskoka et
j'en étais heureux et c'est cela semble
ridicule mais j'étais heureux parce que
j'avais toujours cru qu'il m'avait
abandonné
j'avais perdu une amie durant une
épidémie de polio dans les années 30
je pense que c'était en 1938 elle m'a
assuré que tout allait bien qu'elle
était heureuse
j'ai aussi vu mes grands-parents venus
m'accueillir je n'avais jamais connu mes
grands-pères tous deux morts avant ma
naissance
mais j'avais connu mais grand-mère et ma
mère
abb m'est apparu il m'a dit je suis ton
frère je lui ai répondu je n'ai pas de
frère nous parlions évidemment pas comme
je vous parle pas de confusion possible
il s'agissait d'une sorte de télépathie
c'était un tout petit enfant avec un
bonnet longue robe de tricoter des
bottines des socquettes
il m'a dit observer mois et souviens toi
à ton retour parles-en à notre père il
te dira ce qui est arrivé quand je les
raconte est un papa il m'a dit j'en sais
vaguement tu l'as eu seule ta mère le
docteur in mois et qui ont en courant
cela me donne de l'espoir
je sais que quoi qu'il arrive nous nous
reverrons toujours inconnu parce qu'on a
mené nos parents nos amis déjà disparu
tous ces témoins nous encourage à suivre
cette lumière
ils nous font savoir que tout ira bien
oh
lettre de lumière qui le dit souvent
avoir rencontré est en fait une
incarnation mêmes ils la décrivent comme
la matérialisation de l'amour total qui
les accepte et les chéris il connaît
parfaitement leur personnalité message
plein de tension en somme mais aussi
doté d'un fantastique sens de l'humour
c'était là le plus merveilleux
cette lumière jour et monde elle est
masculine mais avec les accents de
l'amour d'une mère d'une seule tous
vivent autour de lui accepter m'a
pardonné
est-ce que je peux moi-même me pardonner
mais égoïsme
décimé toute ma douleur tout mais sans
france a compris ce qui étions laissés
comme si tout ce que je ressentais elle
leur santé aussi
c'était un amour inconditionnel comme
celui que la plupart des parents
ressentent pour leurs enfants
là
quelles étaient mes fautes j'étais aimé
est comprise et saisissez les
motivations de mes actes
c'était une communion d'affection et
d'un amour merveilleux
moi j'étais ainsi ne sachant que faire
tout à coup la pièce est illuminé tout
s'est précipité
quelque chose de profond s'est
manifestée dans cet être spirituel assis
sur un lit en me regardant un cadavre de
brebis at il dit tu es en présence du
fils de dieu de cette lumière est alors
sorti un être extraordinaire
l'homme le plus impressionnant qu'il
m'ait été donné de voir
j'avais vu à ma droite une silhouette
qui se dirigeait vers moi je n'avais
jamais entendu parler d'expérience de
mort approcher
j'aurais été bien incapable de la
définir depuis j'ai entendu parler de
dieu de jésus de moise ou d'un grand
angle je pense que cet être de lumière
était mon mois supérieure et une partie
de moi on regardait une autre qui
sortait de l'expérience de la vie je me
sentais bien et rassurer si les gens
prenaient conscience et le parti vie qui
leur est inhérente
il serait en paix cet être n'étaient
venus que pour que pour s'intégrer mais
sans présence d'un être qui savait tout
de moi qui ai accepté qu'ils m'aimaient
totalement je ne voulais quitter à
cabrer
c'est pour moi l'élément le plus
important de ces expériences de mort
approcher les passionne film que mise en
présence de cet être d'amour qui les
accompagnent il découvre un panorama de
tout ce qui a été le robinet depuis leur
naissance jusqu'à cette mort qui les
appelle will découvre tout cela en un
temps non pas en séquence temporelle
mais dans une vision globale qui leur
est très difficile de décrire tandis que
les murs de l'hôpital s'estompait j'ai
vu les plus minuscules détails de ma vie
depuis ma naissance par césarienne
même mes 20 ans dans cette lumière
j'ai une vision panoramique de ma vie
depuis ma naissance jusqu'aux événements
les plus récents unique à laquelle je
participais en la regardant je faisais
ces choses en même temps que je les
voyais c'était comme un film que l'on
projetait en accéléré j'ai prouvé les
sensations liées au spectacle que
j'avais sous les yeux mais je pouvais me
abstraire observé autour de moi
différentes choses qui s'était passé à
différentes époques de ma vie j'ai vu
défiler mon existence dimension que je
ne peux décrire
c'était une vision
holographique j'en étais à la fois
l'acteur et le spectateur comme au
théâtre
c'est vous et vous savez que c'est vous
que vous voyez d'isner voit qu'il ya une
attraction semblables êtes assis dans
votre siège sa projection vos
environnent et vous avez l'impression
que vous participez à l'action lorsque
l'image se produisent chez nous avais
des frissons
cette vision intégrée c'était comme
comme si je participe et on esprits et
ont pensé me sens bien que je vivais
toute une vie de souffrance en une
période très courte
c'était une vision panoramique
chaque centime hanche chaque pensée
chaque élection le tout simultanément
dès le début j'ai pris conscience de la
manière dont j'avais influencer ce que
j'avais rencontré de mon interprétation
des choses de celle des autres de la
manière dont ils en avaient été affectés
comment juger tout cela avec du recul
toute une vie comme un livre ouvert
imaginez l'ensemble de votre existence
comme un étang et chaque acte de votre
vie comme un caillou ou vous jeter dans
l'eau chaque caillou qui frappe la
surface créé des ronds dans l'eau sert
on empiète les uns sur les autres
de même que chacun de vos actes a des
répercussions sur la vie de vos proches
cela illustre à quel point nous sommes
liés les uns aux autres à quel point
notre manière de penser et d'agir exerce
une influence sur ce qui nous entoure
c'est de cela nos témoins prennent
profondément conscience les témoins
précise que cette vision accélérée ne
restitue pas nécessairement les
événements qu'il s'attendait à revoir
parce qu'ils croyaient essentielle se
substitue souvent un geste altruiste
oublié depuis longtemps on re découvre
des gestes que l'on a accompli de bon
coeur et d une vieille dame relevé un
enfant se courir un inconnu des actes
accomplis sans calcul sans arrière
pensée par simple vente et ce qui n'est
pas généralement considéré comme quelque
chose de grand d'importants toute la
valeur de quelques petits détails ce que
j'avais toujours considéré comme
essentiel n'avait plus d'importance
on ne comptait plus que de petites
attentions portées aux autres aider les
autres les imitent leur donner un coup
de main il profitait en retour de leur
affection
la question était cas du fed estimable
dans ta vie ce panorama me laissait
espérer que j'avais accompli quelques
actes positifs
j'espérais bien sûr qu'il ne remarquait
pas trop ce que j'avais pu faire d'un
peu embarrassant jeunesse j'ai dit
j'étais scout il m'a répondu tu en est
fier il insistait pour que j'avance
quelque chose de vraiment tangible
l'avez compris il souhaitait savoir si
j'avais appris à aimer mon prochain de
la même manière absolue totale
m'accepter
l'essentiel était de s'observer soi-même
d'un oeil critique
il ne s'agissait pas d'être condamné
d'être jugé il n'était question que de
dire regarde le doigt
rendez compte à dieu sur des actes et
des ambitions
l'expérience de la mort c'est
l'expérience de l'amour celui que l'on
reçoit est celui que l'on donne
on découvre en soi quelque chose de plus
noble et de plus généreux qu'on avait
imaginé ces témoins affirmant aussi que
l'être auxquels il se trouve confronté
est intéressé par le savoir qu'ils ont
acquis au cours de leur existence toute
scène de l'ordi contient une leçon ou un
enseignement quelconque qui suscite son
intérêt et lui inspire des commentaires
même après notre mort le processus
d'apprentissage se poursuit ce que nous
apprenons ici ban nous l'emportons avec
nous au delà du message d'amour il y à
celui de la connaissance et de la
compréhension qu'ils ont acquises au
cours de leur vie
après avoir été plongé dans ce cas de
lumière ils ont dû faire le voyage
retour
les en présence de cet être d'amour mais
sans cependant pas du tout décidé on
assiste pour les renvoyer
mais il résiste
je ne voulais pas faire marche arrière
ni hier ni aujourd'hui je ne changerais
ces quelques moments passés là-bas pour
rien au monde
j'ai été contraint de revenir mais je
traînais les pieds m'ont demandé si
j'étais prête à rentrer je voulais
rester dans ce monde de lumière
je me suis retourné j'ai entendu ma
fille et mon mari qui me disait moment
on revient il aurait pété veux tu y
retourner j'ai dit non mais je crois que
ma fille a besoin de moi je n'avais pas
de raison de revenir si ce n'était pour
ma mère qui avait beaucoup souffert
gta cascon qu elle me disait souvent si
tu pars avant moi je te parlerai pas
elle le dit avec tant de conviction
accusé la première leçon c'est l'amour
on fait vim
et c'est lui qui m'a fait rire parce que
franchement je n'en avais pas envie
l'amour m'a ramené l'amour de ce qui met
généralement le disque on leur a donné
le choix poursuivre l'expérience vous
retourner à leurs vies antérieures
elle m'a dit tu as choisi au caire
si tu restes tu vas devoir subir tout ce
qui t'a amené jusqu'ici j'ai passé en
revue toutes ces choses wade
tous ces événements douloureux de ma vie
c'était j'ai prenait le pas sur tout le
reste je ne voulais plus vivre
il n'y avait pas d'échappatoire
si vous essayez de vous tuer et que vous
réussissez vous devez revivre ce
cauchemar depuis le début d'être passé
tout c est pareil plus comment là vous
êtes passé à l'acte et en assumer toutes
les conséquences
vous ne pouvez pas y échapper
on m'a dit alors c'est quoi l'enfer j'ai
répondu que la question n'avait pas été
posée et que ce n'était sûrement pas moi
qu'ils apposeront il aurait pu vérifier
me dire que j'étais sur la mauvaise
liste m'a demandé à quoi ressemble à
l'enfer si c'était un endroit où l'on
brûlait ce que j'ai appris c'est que
l'enfer c'est la séparation d'avec dieu
c'est l'obscurité
celle où je me trouvais d'abord c'est
être séparée de la lumière de l'amour de
dieu de l'infini malaise c'est
évidemment cela l'enfer c'est pour cela
que toutes les religions condamne le
suicide
mes yeux l'enfer c'est d'être condamné à
aller nulle part et nulle part c'est le
néant cela veut dire qu'on vous
expédiera à l'opposé de l'inventer
on leur a dit souvent ce n'est pas votre
heure il vous reste des choses à
accomplir retourner j'étais à la mort le
lundi on m'a emmené on me l'avait on a
procédé à l'autopsié
il était 11 heures du matin ils m'ont
ouvert l'abdomen j'ai été saisi d'une
force résistible qui m'a poussé à faire
un mouvement vers le bas mais j'ai
ressenti une douleur à la tête j'ai
ouvert les yeux
alors j'ai regagné nos propres accords
je me suis rendu compte que je flottais
dans la salle d'urgence au dessus d'un
corps qui était le mien et sur lequel on
s'acharnait et puis
ils se sont arrêtés ils ont jeté un drap
sur moi ils ont rempli un papier et ils
nous transporter dans une autre pièce
jeux planer au dessus de ce corps je
l'observé
ensuite j'ai entendu le bruit d'une
porte d'ascenseur de gars sont entrés et
il s'apprêtait à m'emmener sans doute la
mort c'est à ce moment précis que j'ai
regagné mon corps il était brûlant il
souffrait je ne pouvais pas bouger
alors j'ai commencé à souffler sur le
drame ils ont arraché ils m'ont ramené
dans la salle d'urgence
ils m'ont examiné ils m'ont soigné une
ex pendant sept jours j'étais
complètement paralysé ils ont atteint
les ultimes frontières de la ville
lorsqu'ils reviennent
il affirme que ce qu'ils ont ressenti de
plus intense c'est l'amour qu'ils
portent à leur prochaine
baines qui fait là profondément
bouleversé mon existence je suis devenu
beaucoup plus compréhensif je sais que
je n'ai aucun droit sur ma propre vie je
ne voulais pas revenir et je voudrais
retourner là bas un jour je le ferai et
j'espère pouvoir y rester
vous connaître à nouveau cette
expérience mais je sais aussi que je ne
peux pas décider
ce n'est pas ainsi que ça se règle je
pense que ça m'a rendu meilleur je me
soucie des autres je suis moins égoïste
je me suis encore je ne suis qu'un être
humain mais j'ai changé des mets des
autres de leur pardonner
peux-tu ça je vais me mettre à leur
place pour les comprendre aimer autrui
pour s'aimer soi même
l adversaire si vous entretenez des
rancoeurs elles vous font mal
et elles font du mal autour d'une idée
ap à toi
ne pas pardonner c'est tuer on ne peut
pas toujours oublier le mail quand vous
a fait mais il faut comprendre et
pardonner relais la forme d'amour que
j'ai découverte
nous sommes tous pareils nous sommes
tous mais c'est le message que j'ai
retenue l'amour est immuable d'amour est
indissociable de la vie l'amour motive
notre existence
l'amour c'est l'éternité d'amour est
l'élément fondamental de la race humaine
l'amour l'amour nous fait vivre ce qui
me paraît important dans ces expériences
de mort approcher
c'est qu'elles ont été vécus aussi bien
par des enfants que par des adultes
les gens devraient comprendre qu'ils
doivent porter plus d'attention aux
autres porter foi et espoir leur
prochain nous pourrions ainsi commencé à
avoir confiance en dieu
pas en termes de valeurs religieuses
mais spirituelle
en termes d'amour tout est possible
en eux toute peur de la mort a aussi
disparu
la vie m'est apparu comme une lumière
infini comme un être éternel nous sommes
éternels nous avons été créés pour vivre
indéfiniment l'esprit assure l'éternité
j'ai compris aussi que la vie n'était
qu'une étape
la mort ni chlore un obstacle à franchir
la mort n'existe pas il ne faut pas en
avoir peur d'aller comme un aiguillage
qui vous conduit vers une autre ville
c'est réconfortant d'entendre ces
témoins qui ont exploré des frontières
de la vie et qui annonce qu'elle se
poursuit au delà de la mort physique
je sais maintenant que si nous partons
nous nous retrouverons dans ce que tu
appelles un flash quoi qu'il arrive tu
dois savoir que je suis heureux de
t'avoir hors pair et que je t'aime
avec tout mon amour
ce sera un voyage paisible vous ne me
ferez pas seul vous serez entouré d'un
immense amour et lorsque vous arriverez
à bon port
et même si certains reviennent comme ce
fut notre cas sachez que tout cela a été
méthodiquement réglé par dieu il a
préparé notre ville et celle guy succès
vous ne mourrez pas l'amour de dieu peut
que vous existez pour toujours vivre et
simplement ailleurs
ces trois semaines plus tard que nous
avons appris la nouvelle
il est mort dans un sourire ces derniers
m'ont été la lumière
oh